chaque réplique est un pari je pense que
ça c'est utile de réfléchir en ces
termes pour savoir comment prendre des
décisions lorsque l'on choisit de
débattre de telle ou telle manière
en fait à chaque fois que l'on dit
quelque chose d'une certaine manière il
semble utile d'être dans cette
perspective où on se réfléchit au
préalable
à quelles vont être les réactions
probables les différents interlocuteurs
à ce que ça va les faire réfléchir
est-ce que ça va les énerver est-ce que
ça les agace et est-ce que ça va
améliorer la discussion à ce que ça va
la rendre plus néfastes ou moins
efficaces pour une bonne c'est quelque
chose que j'ai commencé à essayer de
faire depuis très peu depuis il trop peu
une ambiance et je trouve ça assez
intéressant parce que ça nous force du
coup à être beaucoup plus dans
l'anticipation de la suite du débat et
surtout à réfléchir à quelles seront les
effets probables de notre manière de
débattre c'est carrément ça semble
indispensable pour à chaque du bâton
alors si je caricature un petit peu il
ya eu deux grandes façon d'utiliser ces
parier en pratique la première façon
c'est de choisir leur phrase à dire qui
va maximiser ce qu'on veut maximiser
dans le débat nous par exemple fait
réfléchir les gens quelle est la phrase
que je veux dire que va faire le plus
réfléchir des gens et pour répondre à
cette question bat on peut imaginer
différentes phrases qu'on va dire un tel
moment de la discussion peut dire cette
phrase a eu cette phrase b et pour
pouvoir choisir ce qu'on va dire ce qui
est utile c'est de se demander quelles
sont les conséquences de dire la phrase
sur notamment la réaction de
interlocuteurs et quelles seront les
conséquences de dire la phrase b est
ensuite bien sûr il s'agit de choisir la
phrase qui va avoir le plus de chance de
conduire à des conseillers france que
l'on juge bénéfique
une autre façon d'utiliser cette
histoire de paris c'est de choisir
plutôt une phrase qui veut faire en
sorte qu' il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes
sur la réaction de l'autre parce que ça
va nous permettre d'apprendre finalement
beaucoup de l'autre c'est lié à cet
effet de surprise quand on est surpris
par quelque chose de ces le mouvement du
coup d'ajuster nos croyances et du coup
d'apprendre d'en savoir plus et du coup
si on veut apprendre dans un débat
notamment apprendre de l'autre apprendre
sur l'autre c'est intéressant de choisir
des répliques pour lesquels il ya une
grande incertitude quant à la réaction
de l'autre parce que typiquement quel
que soit ce que l'autre dit on sera un
peu surpris et ça va nous forcer un peu
à mettre à jour nos croyances et du coup
à apprendre et bien sûr le mieux c'est
quand on peut avoir une réplique qui
fait les deux à la fois c'est à dire
qu'ils vont à la fois atteint nos
objectifs en termes de fair afficheurs
élan par exemple et en plus de ça nous
permettent d'acquérir de l'information
et bien sûr ce sont des questions en
fait c'est souvent il ya des questions
qu'on arrive à atteindre ces deux
objectifs à la fois
conséquence du coup de toute cette
élection c'est que il faut analyser la
réaction de l'autre à la lumière de ce
pari qu'on a fait au préalable tivement
sait ce que l'autre dit nous agace et on
n'est pas surpris qu est-ce que c est
grâce qui disent quelque chose que ce
qui nous agace ben finalement ça sans
doute que la phrase comme on a dit au
préalable qui a causé cette réaction
était une mauvaise décision puisque on
aurait dû faire le pari en tout cas au
moment de dire cette phrase que ça
allait conduire à une mauvaise réaction
de l'autre et du coup ce que ça nous
agace et peut-être du coup à ce que le
débat dégénère oua et en tout cas moins
bien donc si on est agacé par quelque
chose dont on n'est pas surpris
c'est peut-être le moment de se remettre
en cause et notamment de réfléchir à
cette guillotine de rim l'inversé dont
faisait preuve un précédent qui
correspond au fait qu' on a tendance à
confondre ce qu'on voudrait du monde
voudrait la manière dont on voudrait que
le monde soit avec le monde tel qu'il
est et en particulier a tendance à être
agacé à chaque fois que l'on constate
que le monde n'est pas tel qu'on
voudrait qu'il soit sauf que ça c'est
une nouvelle façon affiche puisque le
monde tel qu'il est il est tel qu'il est
et le monde tel qu'on voudrait qu'il
soit n'est pas nécessairement le monde
tel qu'il est
bref tout ça ce sont bien sûr des
conséquences de réfléchir en termes de
paris et en particulier les deux
dernières vidéos de la série sur bèze
les épisodes 24 et 25 s'ils ne font pas
sont extrêmement pertinent en fait à
toute sorte de prise de décisions de
façon générale et en particulier la
décision de qu'est-ce qu'on va dire
pendant un débat comment est-ce qu'on va
réagir à ce que l'autre dit bien sûr
tout ça c'est impossible c'est un calcul
impossible à faire en pratique pendant
un débat
donc faut absolument pas dire qu'il faut
absolument appliquer ses calculs va et
vient tout le temps dans un débat mais
c'est intéressant de temps en temps se
réfléchir à ces bons réflexes avoir
notamment ceux demandés lorsqu'on a des
décisions des paroles qui sont qui
risque d'être un peu chaude qui risque
de faire en sorte que des boss et
dégénère vraiment prendre le temps de
s'arrêter un peu et de se demander
qu'est ce que j'ai à quoi je m'attends
quels sont les paris que je fais sur la
réaction de l'autre et de la même façon
quand on est surpris parce que l'autre
dit c'est intéressant de se demander
qu'est ce que j'aurais parié et est ce
que j'ai vraiment raison d'être surpris
et qu'est ce que je dois faire pour être
mieux capable d'anticiper les réactions
des différentes personnes donc voilà je
vous invite à les revoir ces deux vidéos
action extrêmement pertinente pour
acheter du bâton et plus généralement
dans la manière dont vous débattez à
réfléchir un peu plus à quelles seront
les conséquences probables de votre
façon de débattre